Remember when Pluto was a planet?
Until very recently,
Pluto's planetary status
was an immutable fact learned by
primary school kids the world over.
Pluto had an undisputed place
in papier mâché models
of the solar system
and even its very own song lyric -
'And last of all there's
Pluto too...'
But in August 2006,
Pluto found itself cruelly demoted
to a dwarf planet
after failing to meet
one of three criteria
the International Astronomical Union
uses to define a full-sized planet.
We are taught from an early age
to think of scientific facts
as, well, facts.
And it can be unsettling when this
turns out to not be the case.
But does this uncertainty really mean
that we can't trust science?
According to the Royal Society,
the world's oldest independent
scientific academy,
the answer is quite the opposite.
Questioning established facts
is actually at the heart of the
scientific method.
Think of the whole process as a giant
system of checks and balances
based on raw information
drawn from experiments
or observations of nature.
Those experiments and observations
lead to the formulation
of a hypothesis
which then goes through a rigorous
process of checks
by other scientists.
However, there isn't always
enough information
to draw the right conclusions.
Take for example Sir Francis Bacon,
who noticed that the coastlines of
West Africa and eastern South America
looked like they were symmetrical.
He believed that nature
was copying herself.
What he couldn't have known
in the early 1620s
was that the two coasts are two sides
of a fault-line in an
ancient supercontinent
which split apart
140 million years ago.
Bacon's hypothesis remained
gospel for centuries,
until new discoveries about the
science of plate tectonics
emerged in the 1950s
and provided a neat explanation
for Bacon's observation.
There's also the fact that different
experts examining the same raw data
can draw different conclusions.
Spare a thought for poor Robert Plot
who, in the 1670s,
found a fossilised bone that he
thought was that of a giant human.
At least he wasn't around when
a geologist and zoologist
proved it was in fact a Megalosaurus,
a kind of dinosaur that roamed
the Earth in the middle Jurassic.
Sometimes the scientific
method is all about
setting up ground-breaking
experiments at the right time,
in the right place to test theories.
In 1919, a blockbuster meeting
of the Royal Society
confirmed Einstein's theory
of general relativity
after a solar eclipse provided
the perfect circumstances
to measure the bending of starlight.
This showed that the gravity
of a massive object, such as the Sun,
could bend light around it.
Under the watchful eye of
Sir Isaac Newton's portrait,
the scientific community replaced
Newton's previous theory
with Einstein's newer and more
general interpretation of gravity.
But even with evidence in its favour,
Einstein's theory still can't be
thought of as a fundamental fact.
It's even possible that in the future
new breakthroughs will supersede
our understanding
of general relativity.
Uncertainty in science isn't enough
if all the perspectives are the same.
Sometimes a lack of diversity
in the system can skew the results.
Until the 1970s,
primatologists were mostly men
and tended to limit their studies
to male primates.
They believed that the aggression
observed in baboons
meant human evolution had been driven
by similar behaviour.
That was until anthropologist
Shirley Strum
began observing both
female and male baboons,
disproving these earlier theories
and facing a backlash
for her troubles.
Scientists don't always get it right
on the first go.
But rather than instilling doubt,
it should inspire confidence
that outdated ideas are replaced when
new information becomes available.
It's the difference between
upgrading your mobile
and clinging to your old rotary phone
because you don't want to be wrong.
And in most cases,
newer breakthroughs
would not be possible without the
legwork that came before them.
While the rotary phone isn't the best
available technology today,
your smart phone wouldn't exist
without it.
Uncertainty is baked into
the scientific process.
It's the fundamental reason
that progress is possible.
Ultimately, it comes down
to who you trust more -
the person who's certain
they're right,
or the person who's willing
to be proved wrong.